This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Logos used to be a thing that people really didn't give much thought to. Over the last decade, the volume and intensity of arguments about logos have increased substantially. A lot of this is just the internet being, you know, the internet. But logo redesigns in particular attract a lot of hyperbolic vitriol. I was wondering what this felt like to a designer, so I talked to one of my favorites. Michael Beirot is an AIGA metalist and partner at the International Design Consultancy Pentagram, where his work includes brand identity, logos, book design, and packaging.
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。过去，标志并不是人们会过多思考的东西。在过去的十年里，关于标志的争论在数量和激烈程度上都大幅增加。这很大程度上只是互联网在扮演它、你知道的、互联网的角色。但特别是标志的重新设计，往往会吸引大量尖刻、夸张的恶评。我很想知道这给设计师带来了怎样的感受，于是我采访了我最喜欢的设计师之一。迈克尔·贝鲁特是 AIGA（美国平面设计协会）奖章获得者，也是国际设计咨询公司五角设计联盟的合伙人，他的作品包括品牌识别、标志、书籍设计和包装。
I had such a fun time talking with them, I just thought I'd put our conversation out as its own episode. I hope you dig it. Many of you might be familiar with the logos we discuss, but if you need a little help drawing your memory, this is a great episode to listen to as you scroll through the images on this episode's webpage at 99pi.org. Michael says that for a very long time, no one understood what his job as a graphic designer really meant, but recently, that's changed. I have to admit, now a lot of times people will say, oh, so do you do logos? Or they'll outright ask me what I think of, you know,
我和他们聊得非常开心，所以觉得不妨把我们的对话作为单独的一期节目发布。希望你们会喜欢。你们中的很多人可能对我们讨论的标志很熟悉，但如果你需要一点记忆唤醒，边听这期节目，边浏览 99pi.org 本期网页上的图片，会是一个绝佳的体验。迈克尔说，在很长一段时间里，没有人真正理解他作为一名平面设计师的工作意味着什么，但最近情况变了。我不得不承认，现在很多时候人们会说，哦，所以你是做标志的吗？或者他们会直接问我对、你知道的、
some logo that's in the news. And this is entirely new and kind of startling and unnerving. What is the most recent logo they've asked you about? Have you even asked about your own logo? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. No, I was like as if they didn't know. Oh, no.
新闻里某个标志的看法。这完全是崭新的，而且有点让人吃惊和不安。他们向你问起的最近的一个标志是什么？甚至有人问过你关于你自己的标志吗？哦，对。哦，对。哦，对。不，我当时的感觉就像他们不知道一样。哦，不。
Oh, absolutely. I was back in early 2015. I was engaged in a secret project, which was to design a logo for the campaign of, as of yet undeclared candidate for President Hillary Clinton. And it launched. There was a huge amount of attention to this logo, which, you know, became ubiquitous, I think, the age with the arrow in it. And at one point, before it was widely known that I was a designer of it, I got an email from a magazine saying that they were convening a bunch of designers to volunteer to say how
哦，绝对是的。那是 2015 年初。我参与了一个秘密项目，即为当时尚未宣布参选总统的希拉里·克林顿的竞选活动设计一个标志。然后它发布了。这个标志受到了极大的关注，你知道的，它后来无处不在，我想，那个带有箭头的字母 H。在它被广泛知道我是设计者之前，我收到了一家杂志的邮件，说他们正召集一群设计师自愿发表意见，谈谈
they would have designed the logo, because it was so horrible. And so like, we'd like to know, how would would have designed the logo because it was so horrible. And so like, we'd like to know, how would you have designed it if you could have done anything? And I sort of, you know, I just said, oh, you know, I think I'll pass this time. So tell me a bit more how the Hillary logo came about. It used to be that people would run for political office and they didn't understand that they needed a logo and maybe they didn't need a logo. Barack Obama changed all that in 2008. He ran and he had this now famous O for Obama in blue with sort of red stripes leading
他们会如何设计这个标志，因为它实在是太糟糕了。所以就像是，我们想知道，如果你可以做任何事，你会如何设计这个标志？然后我，你知道的，我只是说，哦，你知道的，我想我这次就不参加了。所以，跟我多讲讲希拉里标志的诞生过程吧。过去，人们竞选政治职位时，并不明白他们需要一个标志，也许他们也确实不需要标志。巴拉克·奥巴马在 2008 年改变了这一切。他参选时有了这个现在著名的、蓝色的奥巴马字母 O，里面有某种红色的条纹一直延伸到
into the center of the O with the O kind of symbolizing a setting or probably more likely a rising sun And that symbol was so ubiquitous both in 208 the fact that he won kind of Seal the deal it appeared over the next eight years representing his candidacy and we'll go on to Brand I assume his foundation and his library and his post activities. With that kind of established as a benchmark for political campaigns, by the time 2016 rolled around every candidate, one way or another had one bail at logo, and very early on in 2015, the beginning of the year I got a call from a team that was consulting with Hillary Clinton. They asked me whether I would volunteer my services to create a logo for Secretary Clinton.
O 的中心，O 某种程度上象征着落日，或者更有可能是初升的太阳。那个符号是如此无处不在，无论是在 2008 年他获胜的事实上，还是给它盖上了定音的印章，它在接下来的八年里一直出现，代表着他的竞选活动，并且我猜，它还将继续为他的基金会、图书馆以及他卸任后的活动提供品牌支持。随着这种形式被确立为政治竞选的基准，到了 2016 年大选来临之际，每位候选人都通过某种方式拥有了一个大选标志。早在 2015 年初，也就是年初的时候，我接到了一支为希拉里·克林顿提供咨询的团队的电话。他们问我是否愿意志愿提供服务，为克林顿国务卿创建一个标志。
And what we wanted to do was exploit some of the characteristics that people had come to appreciate. I think possibly by accident about the Obama logo, one of which was that it could be adapted into different forms. You could kind of like customize it for different groups of voters or different locations.
我们想要做的是利用一些人们已经开始欣赏的特征，我想这可能是奥巴马标志偶然带来的，其中之一就是它可以被调整为不同的形式。你可以针对不同的选民群体或不同的地点对其进行某种定制。
And so we had this idea like what if we had a symbol that you could change every day if you wanted, you could make it celebrate LGBT rights one day and celebrate veterans the next day and then modify it for Memorial Day the day after that or Halloween the day after that. That required something very simple. So we came up with this very simple age with an arrow going through it, kind of symbolizing we thought that the candidate
所以我们有了这样一个想法：如果我们有一个符号，如果你愿意，你可以每天都更换它，你可以让它有一天庆祝 LGBT 权益，第二天庆祝退伍军人阵亡纪念日，再过一天为阵亡将士纪念日进行修改，或者在随后的万圣节再次修改。这就需要非常简单的东西。于是我们设计了这个非常简单的字母 H，中间穿过一支箭头，我们认为这象征着候选人
was moving the country forward and also giving us a way to kind of point that age at other things, meaning that Hillary was for, or veterans or for LGBT rights, or for me. And it's just kind of like proved to be a really interesting malleable, lively system in the end. You know, it's interesting because it's this sort of device, you know, for one thing, no one really votes, people don't vote for logos.
正在推动国家向前发展，同时也为我们提供了一种将这个 H 指向其他事物的方式，意味着希拉里是为了什么，或者为了退伍军人，为了 LGBT 权益，或者为了我。最后，这证明是一个非常有趣、具有可塑性且充满活力的系统。你知道，这很有趣，因为这是一种这样的装置，你知道，一方面，没有人真的去投票，人们不会为了标志而投票。
They vote for candidates and they vote for people who they think will improve their lives in some actual way, not people that have flashy logos. But often it's some tangible symbol will crystallize in the voting public's mind, the essence of what a candidate is. And I think just as Hillary perhaps had that age with an arrow in it, and by the time it was election day, I was seeing it everywhere and certainly, you know, at the convention center, the Javits convention center that night for what was meant to be the victory party. People had an embroidered on their jackets, temporary tattoos on their faces. It was everywhere.
他们投票给候选人，他们投票给那些他们认为能以某种实际方式改善他们生活的人，而不是投票给拥有炫目标志的人。但通常情况下，某种有形的符号会在投票公众的心中具象化一个候选人的本质。我想，正如希拉里可能拥有那个带箭头的 H 一样，到了选举日那天，我到处都能看到它，当然，你知道的，那天晚上在会议中心，即贾维茨会议中心，为了那场本该是庆祝胜利的派对，人们把它绣在夹克上，脸上贴着临时纹身。它无处不在。
It was interesting. At the same time, her opponent had a red hat with the slogan on the front of it. And that in a way was a logo for that candidacy. So I think there's the substance of what people are promising and there's sort of the tangible bit of shorthand that kind of sums up what that promise is. And I think that in the commercial world, that's what symbols have always done, you know, you're meant to kind of ascribe all sorts of higher transcendent values to things like basketball sneakers and soda and SOTOPOPs, you know, and instead the transcendent values are then athletic achievement and
这很有趣。与此同时，她的对手戴着一顶正面印有标语的红帽子。从某种意义上说，这也是那场竞选活动的标志。所以我觉得，既有人们承诺的实质内容，也有那种能够概括这一承诺的、有形的简写符号。我认为在商业世界中，符号一直以来做的就是这件事，你知道的，你要把各种更高超验的价值赋予诸如篮球鞋、苏打水和汽水之类的事物，你知道的，而相反，这些超验的价值随后分别变成了运动成就和
refreshment respectively and somehow devices like swishes or Dynamic ribbons or whatever you want to say are kind of meant to be the holders of that meaning that is then kind of reinforced by advertising and by hopefully actual firsthand experience with the product. It's interesting. I never really thought of the hat being a logo. Could you sort of pull apart some of its qualities as to what it's conveyed to you and why
提神醒脑，不知为何，诸如耐克的勾子（Swoosh）或动态丝带之类的设计，或者无论你想怎么称呼它们，都被赋予了承载这种意义的作用，这种意义随后会通过广告以及对产品的实际第一手体验得到强化。这很有趣。我从来没有真正想过那顶帽子是一个标志。你能否剖析一下它的某些特质，比如它向你传达了什么，以及为什么
it works. I think what was interesting about Donald Trump's red make America great hat was that one, it's very, it's a very populist sort of thing. It's clearly not something one associates with coastly leads, you know, who are intellectuals. Although I know, I, hey, I have baseball caps and wear baseball caps. So, you know, and, and so maybe I'm not an elite, I'm from Ohio after all, but it's definitely not suited for a black tie or a business attire. It's meant to be the kind of thing you associate maybe with hardworking, saltedly or with
它能起作用。我认为唐纳德·特朗普红色的“让美国再次伟大”帽子有趣的地方在于，第一，它非常具有民粹主义色彩。它显然不是那种让人联想到代表知识分子的沿海精英的东西。虽然我知道，嘿，我有棒球帽，也会戴棒球帽。所以，你知道，也许我不是精英，毕竟我来自俄亥俄州，但它绝对不适合搭配黑领结或商务正装。它旨在成为那种让你联想到努力工作、脚踏实地的人，或者
Americans. The fact that it's red is making of making a really clear statement about red America, let's say, and the slogan make America great again, all caps, you know, cap locked, yelling aptly, I think, kind of reminded people of the candidate's own delivery of those words. And I think most importantly, it wasn't an underground thing. It was very visible. If you sort of wore a supporter, you put that thing right on your head. And it was like, if someone was looking at your face,
美国人的东西。它是红色的这一事实，对所谓的红色美国做出了非常明确的表态，而标语“让美国再次伟大”（Make America Great Again）全部大写，你知道的，开启了大写锁定，恰如其分地大喊大叫，我认为这在某种程度上让人想起候选人本人传递这些词汇的方式。我认为最重要的是，它不是什么地下暗号。它是非常显眼的。如果你戴着支持者的帽子，你就会把它直接戴在头上。这就好像如果有人看着你的脸，
they would look at that hat and they'd read those words. Wearable brands like that, sort of tattoos, are sort of the big commitment you make to kind of advertising someone else's cause. And so I assume that he had buttons and stickers and signs and stuff like that, but that hat, which is meant to be worn, was like really calling on people to personally identify what they candidate in a really unequipical way. So the Hillary age with an arrow logo is released,
他们就会看着那顶帽子并阅读那些文字。像这样的可穿戴品牌，比如纹身，是你为宣传别人的事业而做出的重大承诺。所以我猜他也有徽章、贴纸和标语牌之类的小玩意，但那顶注定要戴在身上的帽子，真的在召唤人们以一种毫不含糊的方式将自己与候选人进行个人认同。因此，希拉里的带箭头 H 标志一经发布，
and people react to it the way they react to any logo right now, which is a really active discussion online, whenever a new one is done. Yeah. And it's also in the context of this political campaign where she got an unbelievable amount of criticism, no matter what she did. Yeah. But I remember people reacting to the H with the arrow,
人们对它的反应就像他们现在对任何标志的反应一样，每当有新标志诞生时，网上总会引发非常活跃的讨论。是的。而且这也是在这场政治竞选中发生的，无论她做什么，她都受到了难以置信的批评。是的。但我记得人们对带有箭头的 H 的反应
really strongly, some of it quite negative. Were you prepared for that in any way? What had taken me back and what I should have seen coming is that logo, which I actually personally thought was, and still think, was really good. I mean, it was exactly the one that we wanted the campaign to use. We were confident that over the course of the campaign, it would be used in all sorts of ways that would win people over. And I think that was largely proven out.
非常强烈，其中有一些相当负面。你对此有什么心理准备吗？让我始料未及且我本该预料到的是那个标志，我个人当时认为，并且现在依然认为，它真的很好。我的意思是，这正是我们希望竞选团队使用的标志。我们确信，在竞选过程中，它会被以各种赢得人心的方式使用。我认为这一点在很大程度上得到了证明。
I mean, I think by the time November came around, if you sort of like went on the Pant suit nation Facebook page, you would see a million different expressions of it, all homegrown and grassroots and really, really fun. And I remember saying while we were working, while we were looking at all the different options of the logo, I remember saying, I want something that's so simple that a first grader could do it with construction paper, Elmer's glue and kindergarten scissors. You know, I didn't want a fancy thing. You needed to know
我的意思是，我想到了 11 月的时候，如果你浏览一下“裤装国家”（Pantsuit Nation）的 Facebook 主页，你会看到它的一百万种不同表达，全都是本土创作、自下而上且真的、真的很有趣。我记得在我们工作的时候，在我们查看标志的所有不同选项时，我曾说过，我想要一个非常简单的东西，一年级小学生用手工纸、爱 Elmer 胶水和幼儿园剪刀就能做出来。你知道的，我不需要那种精美的东西。你需要懂
software programs to create. I wanted something that was as easy to draw as a heart or a peace sign or a smiley face. You know, something that could be that ubiquitous. And I think we got pretty close to it. It's just a very simple piece of geometry and two primary colors. Now, really though, what happens when somebody like that is launched put out there into, you know, the uncairing world, people treated as a, it's open-endedness, actually, at that moment, works against it. It's open-ended, and it's actually, at that moment, works against it. It's treated as a Rorschach bloat, and everyone projects things onto it, right? And this happens with sports teams. It happens with colleges and universities.
软件程序才能创作出来。我想要一个像画一颗心、一个和平标志或一个笑脸一样容易绘制的东西。你知道的，是可以那样无处不在的东西。我想我们已经相当接近这个目标了。它只是一个非常简单的几何图形和两种原色。然而，说实话，当这样一个标志被推出并置于，你知道的，这个冷漠的世界中时，人们对待它的方式——其实它的开放式特性在那个时刻反而对它不利。它是开放式的，而且在那个时刻其实对它不利。它被当作一个罗夏墨迹测验，每个人都把自己的东西投射到它上面，对吧？这在运动队身上也会发生。在高校里也会发生。
But I think I underestimated to the degree to which it would happen with the political candidate, where someone is well-known as Secretary Clinton. You know, there's a lot of people who have opinions about it already. And then suddenly they have this convenient thing upon which to project opinions they may have already had, or opinions that they just thought were clever, or whatever it was. And so suddenly, you know, I kind of would marvel.
但我认为我低估了这种现象在政治候选人身上发生的程度，尤其是像克林顿国务卿这样知名度很高的人。你知道，很多人对此已经有了看法。然后突然之间，他们有了一个方便的载体，可以将他们原本可能就有的看法，或者他们认为很聪明的看法，或者无论什么看法投射到上面。所以突然之间，你知道的，我有时会感到惊叹。
Sometimes I'd say it's just some straight lines, some 90 degree angles, some 45 degree angles, and two primary colors. It doesn't mean, you know, it's, you know, people would say, well, what does it mean? I said, well, it's an H because it's, that's the candidate's name because of H. It's an arrow because she wants to move the country forward and it's red, white, and blue because of America. And that's really the truth. That's what it meant. And yet, you know, I was, I was kind of taking it back, but I shouldn't have been actually.
有时我会说，这只是一些直线，一些 90 度的角，一些 45 度的角，还有两种原色。它并不意味着，你知道的，人们会说，嗯，这是什么意思？我说，嗯，它是一个 H，因为那是候选人的名字，因为 H 代表 Hillary。它是一个箭头，因为她想推动国家向前发展，它是红白蓝三色，因为代表美国。这真的是事实。这就是它的含义。然而，你知道的，我，我当时有点吃惊，但其实我不该感到吃惊的。
And I have to commend the campaign who were resolute about their commitment to it. And in fact, really brought it to life and made it really sing over the subsequent months. In contrast, there was a notorious logo that was unveiled when Donald Trump identified his running mate in the form of Governor Pence, and they had this T.P. ligature that a lot of people thought they saw, you know, unsavory things in, and made fun of it, and animated it in ways that are kind of salacious. And it was like, it just was made to disappear, and kind of blink it. You know, if you unveil a logo and you really are committed to it,
而且我必须赞扬竞选团队，他们对这一标志的承诺坚定不移。事实上，他们在接下来的几个月里真正赋予了它生命力，让它大放异彩。相比之下，当唐纳德·特朗普公布他的竞选搭档彭斯州长时，有一个臭名昭著的标志被揭晓了，他们设计了一个 T-P 连体字，许多人在其中看到了，你知道的，令人不快的东西，并对其进行嘲笑，以某种带有挑逗意味的方式将它做成动画。结果就是，它被直接弄消失了，就像眨眼一样。你知道，如果你揭晓了一个标志并且你真的对此承诺，
the worst thing you can do is sort of blink and sort of say, oops, forget that, we're making that go away and forget you ever saw that. I think if you stick to it and just act like you really mean it, eventually the world will get used to it. And then eventually, if you wait long and people will be outraged if you try to redesign it into something else.
你能做的最糟糕的事就是眨眨眼然后说，哎呀，忘了吧，我们把它撤掉，假装你从来没见过。我认为如果你坚持下去，表现得好像你是认真的，最终世界就会习惯它。然后最终，如果你等得够久，当你试图把它重新设计成别的样子时，人们反而会愤怒。
If you wait long, people will be outraged if you try to redesign it into something else. Do you remember the first time there was a public fight about a logo where normal people like got involved? So for years, kind of like logo redesigns was like a very esoteric thing where people like me who had gone to art school to learn to be graphic designers, would sort of say, did you see they changed the UPS logo? The logo for UPS delivery trucks. And I know who designed the original logo, I know who did the redesign, I know what kind of things to say about it, and everyone would talk about it. So there were little chat rooms on websites where people would comment for days on the pros and cons of things like that. The first time I remember going public was the gap floated a redesign of its logo.
如果你等得够久，当你试图把它重新设计成别的样子时，人们反而会愤怒。你还记得第一次发生关于标志的公开争论、让普通人也参与其中的是什么时候吗？多年来，标志的重新设计就像是一件非常深奥的事情，像我这样去艺术学校学习成为平面设计师的人会说，你看到他们更改了 UPS 的标志了吗？那个 UPS 快递卡车的标志。我知道谁设计了最初的标志，我知道谁做了重新设计，我知道该对它说些什么，每个人都会谈论它。因此，网站上有一些小型聊天室，人们会在那里连续几天对诸如此类事情的优缺点发表评论。我记得第一次走向公众，是 Gap 推出了一次标志的重新设计。
It appeared online and suddenly someone said, oh my God, the gap, the retail store, the gap is going to redesign its logo. And to the surprise of the gap, all these consumers started getting really agitated about and started saying, save the old gap logo, or this new logo is ridiculous. It looks, usually the criticism that's lodged against new logos is that my four year old could have designed that new logo.
它出现在网络上，突然有人说，哦，天哪，Gap，那个零售店，Gap 要重新设计它的标志了。令 Gap 惊讶的是，所有这些消费者开始对它感到非常激动，并开始说，拯救旧的 Gap 标志，或者这个新标志太荒谬了。通常针对新标志的批评是，我四岁的孩子都能设计出那个新标志。
Now, I actually think that's a good thing. I like logos that four year old can design, actually. But to most people, they seem like logos are sophisticated things that need to be designed with complicated equipment by skillful people and they also assume that a lot of money was spent on logos too. So how much was someone paid to do this thing? You know, so I remember that the gap had sort of let this logo float around out there that was not the Blue box with the highly condensed Sarah Plettters GAP that we're all familiar with,
现在，我其实觉得这是一件好事。事实上，我喜欢四岁小孩能设计的标志。但对大多数人来说，标志似乎是复杂的东西，需要由熟练的人用复杂的设备来设计，而且他们也认为标志上花了很多钱。所以别人花了多少钱来做这个东西？你知道的，所以我记得 Gap 当时让这样一个标志在网上传播开来，那不是我们都熟悉的带有高度压缩衬线字母 GAP 的蓝色方块，
but it was a lowercase helvetica with this superimposed faded blue square kind of put off center on the letters. And for some reason, it just really aggravated people. Even I was surprised by that, and people asked me my opinion of it, and I remember a normal person asking my opinion about a logo before, but that became that there was something started happening more and more in the years to follow. So something about social media, something about the internet kind of is enabled all this to happen. And they definitely blinked on that one. Oh yeah. They sort of, you know, I think they denied they have remented, you know, oh, that was just something we were experimenting with.
而是一个小写的 Helvetica，上面叠加了一个褪色的蓝色正方形，有点偏离字母中心。出于某种原因，这真的激怒了人们。甚至连我都对此感到惊讶，人们问我对此的看法，我以前也记得普通人问我关于标志的看法，但从那以后，在随后的几年里，类似的事情开始越来越多地发生。所以，关于社交媒体的某些东西，关于互联网的某些东西，促成了这一切的发生。他们在那个标志上确实妥协了。哦，是的。他们某种程度上，你知道的，我认为他们否认他们曾意图这样做，你知道，哦，那只是我们正在试验的东西。
Don't worry. We've heard our loyal customers loud and clear and never fear we shampoo changing the gap logo And it was interesting is of course, you know, that's a logo doing exactly what it's supposed to do I mean when people are being sold logos They're told that they will be the receptacle of all the passion that the consumers have for a brand which is this kind of weird Hard to express thing, otherwise, but now all of a sudden, this will be the focal object upon which all that love is going to be aimed.
别担心。我们已经大声且清晰地听取了忠实顾客的意见，永远不用担心，我们不会更改 Gap 标志。有趣的是，当然，你知道的，这正是一个标志在做它本该做的事情。我的意思是，当人们被推销标志时，他们被告知，这些标志将成为消费者对一个品牌的的所有热情的容器，而这种热情在平时是一种奇怪的、难以表达的东西，但现在突然之间，这将成为所有这些爱意都将针对的焦点对象。
And naturally then, the customers think that they own the logo. And then when the company has the temerity to change it without asking anyone's permission, suddenly the customers who have been told, this is love this thing, all of a sudden, has changed on them and without warning, and they get, like, freaked out.
自然而然地，顾客就会认为他们拥有这个标志。然后，当公司竟然有胆量在没有征得任何人同意的情况下改变它时，突然之间，那些被告知“要热爱这个东西”的顾客，发现这个东西毫无预兆地被改变了，他们便开始吓坏、抓狂了。
Do you think that general design awareness in the public has made your job easier or harder? Oh, I think it's made it easier, and it's made it more fun, I would say. I've always thought that what I do, what I do is in the most important thing in the world, but I always thought it was important. I've devoted my life to it,
你认为公众普遍的设计意识让你的工作变得更容易还是更难了？哦，我认为它让工作变得更容易了，也更有趣了，我想这么说。我一直认为我所做的事，我做的事并不是世界上最重要的事，但我一直认为它是重要的。我把一生奉献给了它，
and it's gratifying to have people notice it. And I don't think we can ask people to notice our work and think it's worth talking about, and then presume to tell people, but you can only say positive things about it. You know what I think? I mean, if people are gonna talk about it, you'll get uninformed people talking about it,
能有人注意到它，这让人感到欣慰。而且我们不能一方面要求人们注意到我们的工作并认为它值得讨论，另一方面又指望对人们说，但你们只能说它的好话。你知道我是怎么想的吗？我的意思是，如果人们要讨论它，你就会得到外行人的讨论，
you had informed people talking about it And by large people like I think negative comments are always more fun to read than positive ones a rave review It's a little dull to read But I mean I've never had anyone forward me a positive restaurant review You know like on the other hand if the restaurant view of the New York Times takes a restaurant apart You know the relish with which that writer will describe every dish is just a sight to behold. And I think, you know, so I think, you know, its criticism is much more fun to write and more fun to read. And unless we want to go back to having
也会听到内行人的讨论。而且大体上人们——我认为负面评论总是比正面评论读起来更有趣，狂热的好评读起来有点枯燥。但我的意思是，从来没有人转发给我一篇好评如潮的餐厅评论。你知道，另一方面，如果《纽约时报》的餐厅评论把一家餐厅贬得一无是处，你知道那位作家带着怎样的愉悦心情去描述每一道菜，那真是一场视觉盛宴。所以我想，你知道的，批评写起来更有趣，读起来也更有趣。除非我们想回到那种
no one notice what we're doing and pretending like it doesn't matter at all, we should just get used to criticism. And I have, that's for sure. I mean, is there a way to get used to criticism? Like, it'd be figured out, what's your sort of Jiu-Jitsu method of dealing with it? One of my partners and I, Michael Gerricky, and I redesigned the logo for the Big Ten football conference. And it needed to be redesigned because it was called
没人注意到我们在做什么、并且假装这根本不重要的状态，否则我们应该习惯批评。我确实已经习惯了，那是肯定的。我的意思是，有没有什么方法可以习惯批评？比如，如果已经摸透了，你应对它的柔术方法是什么？我和我的合伙人之一迈克尔·杰里基（Michael Gericke）重新设计了十大联盟（Big Ten）橄榄球联盟的标志。它需要被重新设计，因为它被称为
the Big Ten, but it had 11 teams in it. And they had this clever logo that combined the words Big Ten written out with the number 11 kind of hiding by the T for 10. So it was sort of like, you would simultaneously read 10 and 11 while looking at it, which I just thought was a neat solution to a problem which actually shouldn't be focused on. I mean, let's not celebrate this weird disconnect between the name of the conference and the number of actual teams that are in it, and they were going to 12 teams and not even more teams. So the whole thing was they decided to kind of
十大联盟（Big Ten），但它当时有 11 支球队。他们有一个聪明的标志，将拼写出来的“Big Ten”文字与数字 11 结合在一起，11 藏在表示 10 的字母 T 旁边。所以它就像是，你在看着它的同时会同时读出 10 和 11，我当时认为这是对一个其实不该成为焦点的问题的一个巧妙解决方案。我的意思是，我们不要去庆祝这种联盟名称与其中实际球队数量之间的奇怪脱节了，而且他们还要增加到 12 支甚至更多的球队。所以整件事情就是，他们决定
just come up with a logo that wasn't based on the actual number of teams in the conference, which was just called the Big Ten Conference. So we did basically a logo that was made out of the letter is BIG for big, and then we did a treatment of the eye and big and the G and big so it had a double reading as the number 10. And so when that was unveiled, I actually got voicemail about it from people saying, I can't believe you. What's wrong with you people? Those people are the loyal fans.
直接想出一个不基于联盟实际球队数量的标志，尽管它仍然叫十大联盟。所以我们基本上做了一个由字母 BIG 组成的标志，然后我们对 BIG 中的字母 I 和 G 进行了处理，使其具有数字 10 的双重含义。所以当这个标志揭晓时，我确实收到了人们的语音留言，他们说，我真不敢相信你们。你们这些人有什么毛病？那些人可是忠实的球迷。
And I remember someone at the Big Ten conference when this logo launched telling me, this is the passion that makes them sit in those seats when the weather is terrible. The same passion is going to make them take it personally when you fit it with the logo. What happens is once people get over the shock, if you can hold on tight, they'll get used to the new logo and if it's any good at all, it'll soon be the beloved Big 10 logo and people will sort of like then object the next time it's changed.
我记得当这个标志推出时，十大联盟的一位工作人员对我说，正是这种热情让他们在天气恶劣时依然坐在那些座位上。同样的热情也会让他们在你摆弄标志时产生切身的感受。发生的情况是，一旦人们克服了震惊，如果你能坚持住，他们就会习惯新标志，如果它哪怕有一点点好，它很快就会成为备受喜爱的十大联盟标志，而下次它被更改时，人们又会对此提出反对。
As long as people still care about the Big 10, they'll care about it every time it's changed. And I have to admit, we're entering a stage now where I have worked with clients on doing logos and doing updates to logos where I can tell the worst thing that could happen is if no one reacted at all. The best thing would be if everyone loved it, but the worst thing would be if no one noticed. They're happy to take the outrage just because, wow, people really care about us. It's easy for people to care about a sports team or a university, it's a little bit harder
只要人们还关心十大联盟，每次它被更改时他们就会关心。我不得不承认，我们现在进入了这样一个阶段：我曾与客户合作制作标志以及更新标志，我知道可能发生的最糟糕的事情就是根本没有人做出任何反应。最好的事情是每个人都喜欢它，但最糟糕的事情是根本没人注意到它。他们很高兴接受这种愤怒，仅仅因为，哇，人们真的很在意我们。人们很容易在意一支运动球队或一所大学，但要让人们在意一个零售品牌要难一些，不过人们确实对零售店非常忠诚，因为他们把那些服装直接穿在自己身上。我认为，要让人们在意金融机构和在我们的生活中扮演更疏离角色的更抽象的实体，其实要更难一些。但现在所有这些机构在更新标志时都会收到评论，我想你
to make people care about a retail brand, but people do feel very faithful to retail stores because they put those garments right in their bodies. And I think it's actually a little bit harder to make people care about financial institutions and more abstract entities that play a more kind of distant role in our lives. But all of them now will get comments on logo updates and I think that you just who that
用来适应和经受这一切的方法，就是去想，好吧，人们有时会对改变产生强烈的反应，但这种反应的强度实际上与他们对你所代表的特定品牌的情感深度直接相关。所以这既是一个有点坏的消息，也是一个同样好的消息，我认为。你有没有和一个人进行过一对一的互动，比如一个七叶树队（Buckeye）的球迷，深感愤怒，最后结果怎么样？嗯，这就是有趣的地方，以那些七叶树队的球迷为例。我当时有一个回应的政策。
you use to sort of weather it is, you just sort of think, well, people are going to react to change strongly sometimes, but the strength that reaction is actually directly related to the depth of feeling they have about the particular brand that you're representing. So it's a little bit bad news, equally good news, I think. Have you ever had a one-on-one interaction with a person, like a Buckeye fan, just deeply enraged and how did it go? Well, this is what's interesting with those Buckeye fans, for instance. I had this policy of responding.
他们不知怎么发现的，消息传出是我们做的，人们找到了我们的邮箱，我开始收到这些转发的邮件，里面有很多“你怎么敢”或者“你们收了多少钱，你们应该为自己感到羞耻，我那 1923 届的父亲正在坟墓里气得打转”之类的话。我总是会以一种非常礼貌的方式写信回复说，第一，努力工作做出一件东西却发现大家不喜欢，这总是令人失望的。我只能希望你们随着时间的推移，至少能习惯它，理想情况下能像我们一样喜欢它，或者至少不要让它那么困扰你们。但我知道球队非常珍视你们对他们的强烈感情，作为一名共同的球迷，这才是我们真正关注的事情。我会写下这样的话，而且我也是真心实意的。我对其中的每一个字都是真心实意的。然后大约三分之二我写信的人会用一种懊恼的语气回信给我，他们会说，哦，哦，谢谢。我很抱歉。我刚才有点反应过头了。我还是不太喜欢它，但我很高兴听到解释，我很抱歉，我在气头上
They found out somehow it came out that we had done it and people found our emails and I started getting forward these emails that had a lot of how dare you or how much you charge you, you should be ashamed yourself for my father who was class of 23 is spinning in his grave or whatever. And I would always write back in this really kind of courteous way saying, one, it's always disappointing to work hard on something to know that people don't like it. I can only hope that you, over time, come to at least get used to it, ideally come to like it as much as we do or at the very least not have a bother you quite as much. But I know that the team values the strong feelings you have
把那种邮件发给了你。有些人不会道歉，但显然，有一件事非常明显，那就是真正最困扰他们的，是那种巨大的、非个人化的企业力量在任意妄为地改变他们个人所关怀的东西，而完全没有考虑他们作为球迷是谁，球队是什么，或者诸如此类的事情。而且，居然有一个有名字、
about them and as a fellow fan, that's the thing that we all really focus on. I would write something like that and I really meant it too. I really meant every element to that. And then about two thirds of the people I would write to would write me back in this chasin sort of tone where they say, oh, oh, thanks. I'm sorry. I was going over the top a little bit. I still don't like it, but I was happy to hear explanation and I'm sorry, I kind of like
有声音、甚至可能在某种程度上分享他们感受的活生生的人存在，你可以看出这并不是他们脑海中所想象的。如果你只是认为在某个地方，可怕的恶棍正在把某种你喜欢的东西搞砸，而现在它被毁了，我恨你，那这是一个非常容易满足的发泄目标。然后如果突然之间那个真人出现，就会有点那种，哦，我其实并不是那个意思。所以再次强调，我的目标不是去转化这些人。
fire that off to you in the heat of the moment. Somebody wouldn't apologize, but clearly the one thing that was really obvious was that the thing that really bothered them the most was their sense that giant, impersonal corporate forces were arbitrarily changing things that they cared about personally with no thought of who they were as fans and what the team was or anything like that. And the idea that there was a human being with a name
我的意思是，我真心觉得很糟糕。当我设计某样东西时，我其实并不是想惹人生气。我希望人们喜欢我设计的东西。而且我几乎总是坚信，如果我设计的东西制作精良且非常符合其用途，适合球队，球队适合受众，最终人们会开始接受它，并在他们的生活中扮演与它所取代的事物相同的角色。标志很有趣，因为我设计很多东西，比如我设计书衣。书衣有一个真理时刻，那就是你在书店买书时，你走过书架，它吸引了你的眼球，然后你心想，哦，这看起来很有趣，你把它拿起来，决定买下它。
and a voice who might share their feelings in any way whatsoever, you could tell it wasn't what they were picturing. It's a very satisfying target if you just think somewhere up there, horrible people are messing with something that I liked and now it's ruined and I hate you. And then if all of a sudden that person shows up in person, it's a little bit kind of, oh, I didn't quite mean that. So again, my goal, I'm not trying to convert these people.
然后你之后的体验基本上就是和书本身在一起了，书衣所扮演的角色并没有那么重要。然而标志不同，它们是少数随着使用而增值的东西。如果你想象一下，你知道的，现在美国商业景观中那些非常简单且具有标志性的标志，比如 Target（塔吉特）的标志，或者是耐克的勾子（Swoosh）。这些都是四岁小孩就能设计出来的东西，看起来非常简单，没有内涵意义。嗯，Target 的标志有一个让人们感到恼火的含义。如果你雇佣了一些高级设计师来为一家名为 Target 的公司设计标志，
I mean, I sincerely feel bad. When I design something, I actually am not trying to make people mad. I want people to like the thing I design. And I'm sort of almost always convinced at the moment that eventually, if the thing I've designed is well crafted and is really appropriate for its purpose, fits the team, team fits the audience eventually will come to when I play the same role in their lives that the thing did that it replaced. And logos are interesting because I design a lot of things, I design say book covers, let's say. And a book cover it has one moment of truth when you're buying a book in a bookstore, you walk down the aisle and it catches your eye and then you think, oh, this looks interesting, you pick it up and you decide to buy it.
他们回来后说，我们想出了一个非常棒的方案。就是这个。这是一个靶子（Target）。这就像是，这花了多长时间？但我的意思是，想想他们能够通过这个符号的简洁性做到多少事情。想想他们如何能够操纵非常简单的形式来表达各种不同的含义。我想说的是，现在这个标志，不管他们在 60 年代委托设计时支付了多少钱，
Then your experience thereafter is basically with the book itself and the role that the cover played isn't that consequential. Logos though, they're one of the few things that appreciate and value as they're used. If you picture, you know, really simple logos that are iconic in the American commercial landscape now like the target logos, they are the Nike swish. These are things that a 40-year-old could design are really simple looking, have no inherent meaning. Well, the target logo has a meeting that people find exasperating. If you're hiring some fancy design for them to do a logo for a company called Target,
它现在的价值要高出一百倍。当标志公开进行重新设计时，你最不喜欢围绕它们的激烈讨论中的哪一方面？比如，哪种批评会让你觉得，哦，那真是不对。我不知道。哦，好吧，你知道的，如果你设计了某种新东西，人们出于某种原因拼命想把它
and they come back and they say, we came up with something really great. Here it is. It's a target. It's like, how long did that take? But I mean, think about how much they've been able to do with the simplicity of that mark. Think about how they've been able to manipulate very simple forms to mean all sorts of different things. And I would argue that that logo now, regardless of they've been able to manipulate very simple forms to mean all sorts of different things.
和他们已经熟悉的东西联系起来，以至于他们会说，哦，这看起来和另外那个东西一模一样。有时，根据他们的心境，他们会说这看起来和另外那个东西一模一样，那可能是某种含糊不清的东西，比如，你知道的，男性或女性的生理结构之类的。有太多这样的言论在流传。
And I would argue that that logo now, regardless of they paid for it back in the 60s when it was commissioned, it's worth, you know, a hundred times as much now. What is your least favorite aspect of the heated discussion around logos or redesigns when they happen publicly? Like, what is the type of criticism where you just like, oh, that's not. I don't know. Oh, well, you know, if you design something new, people for some reason are so desperate to reconcile it
无论你设计什么，你知道的，他们有一种非常人类的需求，那就是把抽象的形状变成某种具有象征意义的东西。实际上，我的意思是，标志本意应该是一个空容器，意义被倾注其中，而当它们发挥作用时，那个意义就是你对标志所代表的事物的亲身经历。当有人只是说，
with something they're already familiar with that they'll say, oh, that looks exactly like this other thing. And sometimes, depending on their frame of mind, they'll say that looks exactly like this other thing that could be something vaguely muddy, like, you know, male or female anatomy or something like that. There's like so much of that goes around.
哦，那对我说来就像，那看起来像生殖器。你看到了吗？那确实挺难顶的。此外，我其实从未完全犯过这个错误，但如果你是一个执业平面设计师，或者如果你是一个刚入行的年轻平面设计师，我给你的一个建议是，如果你是一个执业平面设计师，如果你是刚入行的年轻平面设计师，我给你的一个建议是，如果你在设计一个标志，比如它是一个准
And no matter what you design, you know, they have this very human need to kind of turn abstract shapes into something figurative that means something. And really, I mean, what logos are meant to be our empty vessels into which meaning is poured and that meaning when they work right is the meaning that your firsthand experience with the thing that's represented by the logo is. And I think when someone just says,
你知道的，一个几何标志，带有一个四部分的结构，具有某种旋转性的、有角度的旋转特征。如果有人说这有点让我想起纳粹万字旗，你会，那，只要，你知道的，这就是一个信号，表明这个标志绝对不能向任何人展示，把它收起来吧，真的。那就好像是，这已经接近了，我的意思是，你可以说它看起来像阴茎，然后你可以克服它，但我的意思是，看起来像万字旗的标志简直就像是，真的，我记得我当时正要去和一个，你知道的，向一个客户进行演示，我私下里
oh, that looks like, that looks like Genitalia to me. Did you see it? That's sort of is tough. Also, I've never actually committed this error all the way, but if you're a practicing graphic designer, or if you're a young graphic designer out there, I'll, one bit of advice I have is if you're practicing graphic designer, if you're a young graphic designer out there, I'll, one bit of advice I have is if you're like working on a logo that is like a, say, it's a quasi,
对一个我真的很喜欢的标志有一点小小的纠结，它有那种几何特征，取决于你如何看待它，你知道的，你知道的，我曾被发现，其实并没有。然后我就要去那里做这个盛大的展示。我需要，我需要有人帮我把东西搬到会议现场。甚至都不是在开会，只是帮我搬进去。那是一个实习生，实习生说，这个看起来有点像万字旗，你知道吗？我记得当时几乎像要哭出来一样说，现在你把一切都毁了。果不其然，我走进会议室。
you know, it's a geometric logo with a, with a four part kind of thing that kind of has a rotational angular rotational aspect. If someone says that kind of reminds me of a swastika, you will, that, just, you know, that's a signal you should, that that logo will not be presented to anyone, just put it away, actually. That sort of is like, that's close to, I mean, you can say it looks like a penis, and like, you can actually get over that, but I mean, logos that look like swastika is just like, really, I remember I was going to a meeting with a, you know, to a client and I had privately
我说，这个，你知道的，客户说，嗯，这个，你知道的，你知道它看起来像什么吧？对吧？我就想，哦，是的，对不起，我刚才在想什么？所以我想我最讨厌这个。如果有人说它看起来像是 20 世纪最邪恶的政治和文化力量的标志，那可真不好。不过这也向你说明，那，你知道的，万字旗几个世纪以来一直是一个完全抽象、无害甚至可以说是仁慈的符号。
had a little twinge with, I did a low I really liked and it sort of had these kind of geometric characteristics that depending on how you looked at it, you know, you know, I've been known, not really. And then so I was going there and I did this big presentation. I needed like, and I needed someone to help me just carry the thing to the meeting. And not even being in the mean, just carrying me in there. It was like an intern and the intern said, this one sort of looked like a swastika to you. And I remember like almost like bursting into tears and saying, now you've ruined everything. And sure enough, I go in the meeting.
它是一个精神徽章，在东方文化中有很多应用，然后被一个人——一个失败的艺术家和他的朋友们劫持了，他们把它变成了他们所塑造的那样，这正说明了这一点。我的意思是，如果有人注意到了这一点。那倒是一个不错的批评，因为显然，你确实希望，我的意思是，当你做这些事情时，你确实希望去问，你知道，这看起来像什么？这让你想起什么？
I said, this one, you know, the client says, well, this one, you know, you see what it looks like. Right? And I'm like, oh, yeah, I'm sorry, what was I thinking? So I guess I hate that the most. If someone says it looks like an emblem of the most evil, political and cultural force of the 20th century, that's not good. And it just goes to show you, though, that was, you know, the swastika was this perfectly abstract harmless and even kind of benevolent symbol for centuries.
而如今，特别是抽象标志的设计师，面临着与那些为产品起名字的人相同的问题，你知道的，就是所有的好名字都被占用了。所有的好网址都被占用了，而且经常所有好的、简单的抽象几何标志也都被占用了。所以很难找到一个还没有被做过的标志。
It was a spiritual insignia that kind of has a lot of application in Eastern culture and then got hijacked by one guy, a failed artist and his friends and they turned it into what they turned it into and it just goes to show you. I mean, somebody notices it. That's a good piece of criticism because obviously, you do want to, I mean, when you're doing these things, you do want to say, you know, what does this look like? What does this remind you of?
当你做这些事情时，你必须进行这些，你知道的，你必须进行这些法律检索。你试图确保没有其他人使用过它。如果你能找到一个精美简单且未被占用的标志，你就会情不自禁地想，哦，天哪，你会觉得自己发现了一片新大陆。哦，天哪。是的。想要扮演国王并宣布自己为王。你有没有见过一个新标志或重新设计标志，随着时间的推移，你的看法发生了最大的转变
And these days, particularly, abstract logo designers have the same problem that people coming up with names for products to, or you know, where it's, you know, we're all the good names we're taking. And all the good URLs we're taking and frequently all the good, kind of simple abstract geometric logos are taken. So it's really hard to find one that hasn't been done already.
而且特别是现在，抽象标志设计者面临着同样的问题，就像给产品起名字一样，你知道的，所有好名字都被用光了。所有的好网址都被占用了，而且通常所有好的、简单的抽象几何标志也都已经被用了。所以要找到一个还没被做过的真的很难。
When you do these things, you have to do these, you know, you do these legal searches. You try to make sure that no one else has used it. If you can find one that's nice and simple that is available, you're just kind of like, oh my, you feel like you've discovered a new content. Oh my God. Yeah. Want to play a guy and declare yourself king. Have you ever seen a new logo or a redesigned logo and over time had the most change of heart
当你做这些事情时，你必须进行这些法律检索。你得设法确保没有其他人用过它。如果你能找到一个既好看又简单而且可用的，你就会觉得，天哪，你就像发现了新大陆一样。天哪，是的。甚至想插个旗子宣称自己是国王。你有没有见过一个新标志或重新设计的标志，随着时间的推移，你的看法发生了最大的改变？
about it like a real strong reaction and then kind of began to love it. Do you remember anything like that where your point of view changed, either for the more positive or for the more negative? Partly because of the way I've been trained and having done this for so many years, my snap judgment about logos is probably more refined than it should be. So there are ones that I saw when they were brand new that I didn't like much then and I still don't like. But a lot of times even if I don't like it, I sort of get what they were going for. There's some that are just outright. I just plain don't like them. Here in New York, we had the longstanding logo of the Metropolitan Museum of Art was
对此有着非常强烈的反应，接着就开始喜欢它了。你还记得有什么类似的事情，让你的观点发生改变，变得更积极或更消极吗？部分由于我受过的训练以及从事这行这么多年，我对标志的第一直觉可能比应有的水准更敏锐。所以有些标志我刚看到时就不太喜欢，现在也依然不喜欢。但很多时候，即使我并不喜欢，我也大概能理解它们的意图。有些则是完全直白的。我就是单纯不喜欢它们。在纽约，我们有一个使用很久的纽约大都会艺术博物馆的标志，它被
replaced with a logo that replaced a drawing of an M with the letters, with letters saying the Met. And a lot of people didn't like it partly because it was new and replacing something that they were used to. And partly because I would concede it was like really idiosyncratic and weird looking. But at the same time I was thinking, you know, but if you go to the Met, you know, it's a big complicated idiosyncratic place. You go there and get lost. It's like really labyrinthin inside. It has so much stuff there to try to represent this thing
替换成了一个新标志，用“the Met”这几个字母替换了原本的字母 M 的图案。很多人不喜欢它，部分是因为它是新的，取代了他们习惯的东西。部分是因为我必须承认，它确实非常古怪且看起来很奇特。但与此同时我在想，你知道的，如果你去大都会博物馆，你会发现这是一个宏大、复杂且奇特的地方。你在里面会迷路。里面真的就像迷宫一样。它有那么多的藏品，如果试图用一个
with something that could look like it was for a pharmaceutical company, something clean and simple, wouldn't be doing it justice. It needs something that kind of feels complicated and idiosyncratic and specific. So I remember, I looked at it, and even now when I see it, it still kind of takes me back sometimes because I was used to the old one like everyone else was.
看起来像是制药公司的标志、某种简洁纯粹的东西来代表这个地方，那就无法体现它的精髓。它需要某种感觉起来复杂、古怪且独特的东西。所以我记得，我看着它，甚至现在我看到它时，有时还是会把我拉回过去，因为我和其他人一样习惯了旧的标志。
But I can recognize that in the long run, I think it will, if they stick with it, I think it'll work and come to be as beloved as its predecessor was. When you say that you plain don't like something, just like in general, what are those things that you plain don't like? Is there a way you could articulate those qualities? I mean, I hate to say it, but just like everyone else, I'll look at something and say, oh my goodness, that's rather ugly, isn't it?
但我能认识到，从长远来看，我认为如果他们坚持使用下去，它会发挥作用，并变得像它的前任一样备受喜爱。当你说你单纯不喜欢某个东西时，就比如说总体而言，那些你单纯不喜欢的东西是什么？有没有办法能把这些特质明确表达出来？我的意思是，我很不想这么说，但就像其他人一样，我会看着某个东西说：“哦天哪，这相当丑，不是吗？”
You know, and like, you know, I mean, for instance, if you want to talk about another design, the design for the 2012 Olympics in London were widely criticized. And I think right, to the degree that it's right to criticize logos, I can really see why people criticize, because I think that was like a darn funny looking logo, because it was like really chunky and jaggedy and kind of cookie looking. But again, I have to admit, I sort of got it. It's like, you know, like a presidential campaign logo, it's sort of only, it had to mark a moment in time.
你知道的，比如，如果我们谈论另一个设计，2012年伦敦奥运会的标志曾受到广泛批评。而且我认为，在批评标志算得上合理的程度上，我确实能理解人们为什么批评，因为我认为那是一个相当滑稽的标志，因为它看起来真的很笨重、有棱有角，而且有点像饼干。但话又说回来，我不得不承认，我某种程度上理解它。就像，你知道的，就像总统竞选标志一样，它某种程度上只是、它必须标记一个特定的时刻。
It wasn't designed to be this enduring thing that would last forever. It just had to kind of like symbolize what was happening in that specific place at a specific time and would be further associated with all these kind of feats of athleticism that would be the actual real experience of the event, not just the logo. And so in a way, something idiosyncratic and specific could come to stand for all those other things.
它并不是为了成为一个能够永远持续下去的永恒之物而设计的。它只需要象征那个特定时间、特定地点正在发生的事情，并进一步与所有这些运动成就联系在一起，这些成就才是事件的真实体验，而不仅仅是标志。因此，从某种意义上说，某种独特而具体的东西可以代表所有这些其他的事情。
However, I still think it's ugly. It's just like ugly. It's sort of ungainly. It's like. It's just like ugly. It's sort of ungainly. It's like weird looking. I could never quite, I have to admit, I personally and privately need to make up a story that explains it. Hence I could make up a lot of stories for the Met logo.
然而，我仍然觉得它很丑。它就是很丑。它有点笨拙。它就像。它就是很丑。它有点笨拙。它看起来很怪异。我始终无法完全——我必须承认，我个人私下里需要编造一个故事来解释它。因此我可以为大都会博物馆的标志编造很多故事。
I could make up a lot of stories for every logo I've ever designed. To me, it's sort of the same pleasure I used to take as a kid, you know, sitting in my dentist's office looking at highlights magazine. They have that thing called Hidden Pictures pictures where it's just drawing us. It's the best, right? It's just drawing and then it says in the picture above, can you find, you know, a teapot, a hairbrush, you know, a basketball, and then you can't see any of those things. Then you see, oh my god, like the hairbrush is the drapes on that window and the basketball is that plate that's in the pantry, you know, and then obviously you're finding all these things.
我可以为我设计过的每一个标志编造很多故事。对我来说，这有点像我小时候得到的乐趣，你知道的，坐在牙医诊所里看《Highlights》杂志。他们有个栏目叫“隐藏的图画”，里面全是画。那是最好的，对吧？它只是一幅画，然后上面写着：“在上面的图片中，你能找到茶壶、发刷、篮球吗？”然后你根本找不到那些东西。接着你突然发现：“哦天哪，发刷竟然是那扇窗户上的窗帘，篮球是储藏室里的那个盘子，”你知道的，然后你显然就找到了所有这些东西。
And there's such pleasure in discovering those things. And if you've got a logo that has that bit of pleasure embedded in it. And I think with, like for instance, when we embedded the 10 in the eye and the gene that big 10 logo, we were trying to do something like that. The most famous instance of it probably with contemporary logos is the arrow that's hidden in the FedEx logo. But I think those little surprises just give people so much, they give them a little bit of joy, make them feel smart, and actually make them complete the picture in their own
发现这些东西会带来巨大的快乐。如果你有一个标志，其中蕴含着这种微小的快乐。我想，就像我们把数字 10 嵌入眼睛和基因里那个大 10 标志时，我们就是想做类似的事情。当代标志中最著名的例子可能就是隐藏在 FedEx 标志里的那个箭头了。但我认为这些小惊喜给人们带来了很多东西，它们带给人们一点点快乐，让他们觉得自己很聪明，并且实际上让他们在自己脑海中
mind. And you have the pleasure of looking at something and making a discovery. And I think if you associate that moment of pleasure with a logo, that really is a great thing. Even if you look at a logo and say, well, all those ligatures are meant to symbolize connection. That's not quite as fun as finding a hairbrush in some window curtains, but it's something. And it works for me these many years later. So last year there was a redesign of the Kodak logo and I interviewed Kira Alexandra of work order who did it and when I talked to her she purposely talked about how they just rolled it out kind of low key and they didn't make a big hell of a blue about it.
完成了整幅图画。而且你拥有看着某样东西并发现它的快乐。我想，如果你把那种快乐的时刻与一个标志联系起来，这真的是一件很棒的事。即使你看着一个标志说，嗯，所有这些连笔都是为了象征连接。这可没有在窗帘里找到发刷那么有趣，但它总归是点东西。多年后的今天，它对我依然管用。所以去年柯达标志进行了重新设计，我采访了负责此事的 Work Order 公司的基拉·亚历山大（Kira Alexandra），当我与她交谈时，她特意谈到他们是如何低调地推出这个新标志的，没有为此大张旗鼓。
I mean it still got criticized in different ways and largely lauded. But, you know, it was kind of a reaction to the brand new thumbs up, thumbs down. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, what do you think of that? Is that a good idea? Do you also, do you feel smirly inclined or do you like to throw it out there and have it be a bit of a bloodsport? You know,, what is your take on that? Well, I used to tell my clients, no one will care when your logo goes out there. Don't take out an ad in the paper and say,
我的意思是，它仍然受到了各种方式的批评，但也大受赞誉。但是，你知道的，这有点像是对全新的“点赞、差评”机制的一种反应。是啊，是啊，是啊。你知道的，你对此怎么看？这是一个好主意吗？你也会、你是否也倾向于沾沾自喜，还是喜欢把它抛向公众，让它变成一场带有血腥运动色彩的争论？你知道的，你对此有何看法？嗯，我过去常对客户说，当你的标志发布时，没有人会在乎。不要在报纸上登广告说：
bold new look, same great taste, you know, like no one cares. You know, I, I used to like joking and say, oh, honey, honey, kids come in. You know, a malgum-ated widget just changed their logo. You know, no one cares. But then we passed through this weird thing where it became this funny kind of like social media enabled blood sport where like, you know, a malgommated widget just changed its logo
“全新的外观，一如既往的美味”，你知道的，就像没人会在乎一样。你知道的，我以前喜欢开玩笑说：“哦，亲爱的，孩子们快进来。你知道的，一家不知名的小公司刚刚换了标志。”你知道的，没人会在乎。但后来我们经历了一件奇怪的事情，它变成了一种有趣的、由社交媒体驱动的血腥运动，就像，“你知道的，一家不知名的小公司刚刚换了标志，
in 321, game on, you know, and it's like, you know, my four year old could do that, how much they pay for this piece of crap, et cetera, you know. So suddenly it turned to this like thing that people did for their own and others' amusement. I still think, though, that these things succeed to the degree that they're actually reflecting something of substance that's really changed in the thing that's represented by the logo. So in the case of Kodak, when they updated that logo, it was meant to mark the rebirth of a beloved American company that to certain generations of photographers really was the gold standard of or just the ubiquitous kind of element in the photographic process. And it was associated with that five-letter
倒计时 3，2，1，游戏开始，”你知道的，就像是，“我四岁的孩子都能做出来，他们为这件垃圾付了多少钱”等等，你知道的。所以它突然变成了一件人们为了自己和别人的娱乐而做的事情。不过我仍然认为，这些标志之所以成功，是因为它们确实反映了标志所代表的事物中某些真正发生实质改变的东西。所以在柯达的例子中，当他们更新那个标志时，它是为了标志着一家备受喜爱的美国公司的重生，对于特定几代摄影师来说，这家公司确实是摄影过程中的黄金标准，或者说是一种无处不在的元素。它与那五个字母的
word codec, especially with the yellow box and with that very simple logo that they had. And when you know, Kira Alexander and her team updated it, they actually were really careful, I thought, insensitive to extrapolating everything they were doing from examples in the past. And I know what pleasure she took. She did one big bold move, which was, instead of writing Kodak, horizontally, she writes it vertically. She stacks the five letters one to top each other, and is able to make a very neat kind of ready for the 21st century and all the requirements that logos have to have today
单词“Kodak”联系在一起，尤其是那个黄色的盒子和他们非常简单的标志。当基拉·亚历山大和她的团队更新它时，我发现他们其实非常小心，并且敏锐地从过去的历史实例中推演出他们所做的一切。我知道她从中获得了多大的乐趣。她做了一个重大而大胆的举动，那就是，她没有水平书写“Kodak”，而是垂直书写。她将这五个字母上下堆叠在一起，从而能够做出一种非常整洁、适合21世纪以及当今标志所必须具备的所有要求的标志。
in terms of reproduction and dissemination. She made a really nice logo with that move and took a great deal of pleasure in finding a couple of examples of the letters being stacked in the same way from deep in the past of the company. So she was able to kind of give the whole thing, this imprimatur, this endorsement from almost beyond the grave from the deep in the history of the company, which I think was really satisfying and actually very effective for them. from the deep in the history of the company, which I think was really satisfying, and actually very effective for them. Is there like a fashion right now that you wrestle against or maybe one that you think
在复制和传播方面。她通过这一举动制作了一个非常漂亮的标志，并且在公司悠久的历史深处找到了几个字母以同样方式堆叠的例子，这让她感到了极大的快乐。因此，她能够为整个事情赋予这种权威性、这种背书，仿佛来自公司历史深处的墓穴之外，我认为这真的令人满意，对他们来说实际上也非常有效。仿佛来自公司历史深处的墓穴之外，我认为这真的令人满意，对他们来说实际上也非常有效。现在是否存在一种你与之抗争的流行趋势，或者你认为
is right? I mean, like simple, for example, is like, I don't think that's, I think it's kind of always been somewhat of a goal in logos, but it seems to take on a real guiding principle right now, maybe more than in the time when somebody wrote a Coca-Cola out as a long script. Is there something today that you really love that you think is a fundamental principle or do you think of it as a fashion or anything like that? I have to admit, I like simplicity of form, but I kind of, sometimes I'm a little suspicious
正确的趋势？我的意思是，比如“简单”，我不认为这——我认为这在标志设计中某种程度上一直是一个目标，但它现在似乎成为了一种真正的指导原则，可能比当年有人把“Coca-Cola”写成流畅的花体字时还要明显。今天有什么东西是你真正喜爱的、你认为它是基本原则的，还是你认为它只是一种流行趋势之类的？我不得不承认，我喜欢形式上的简洁，但我有时对
of simplicity and typography, you know, so I love this typeface called Helvetica, which some people would argue is among, you know, it's a very simple clean and ubiquitous typeface that you know that has represented over the years everything from American apparel to American airlines, you know, chances are no matter where you are, there's some Helbedica on something that you can see from where you're sitting. And if not just take out your wallet, and if you have any American paper currency,
简洁和排版有点怀疑，你知道的，所以我非常喜欢这种名为 Helvetica 的字体，有些人会认为它是其中之一，你知道的，它是一种非常简洁、干净且无处不在的字体，多年来它代表了从 American Apparel 到 American Airlines 的一切，你知道的，无论你在哪里，你坐的地方周围都能看到的东西上很可能都有 Helvetica 字体。如果没有，只需掏出你的钱包，如果你有任何美国纸币，
that big number five on your $5 bill is in hellbedica. So there it is, right? And I think there was a time back in the late 60s where you could take any logo reset in hellbedica and it would look modern, contemporary, and kind of like ready for you know the millennium. And I think I then I fell out of favor and I think I'll be it's come back a little bit so among other things, you know very recently Diane Bonferson The adus and credit, DVF monogram that they have before. Now it's the words Diane von Furstenberg in heo-vettica.
你 5 美元钞票上那个巨大的数字 5 就是用 Helvetica 体印的。所以它就在那里，对吧？我想在 60 年代末的时候，你可以把任何标志用 Helvetica 体重新排版，它看起来就会很现代、当代，并且有点像是为千禧年做好了准备。后来它似乎失宠了，但我认为它现在又回归了一点，所以在最近，戴安·冯·弗斯滕伯格（Diane von Furstenberg）的
It looks clean, it looks neutral, it looks smart, but it also at its worst, not necessarily in this case, but I mean, it has that same sort of glum and impassive and kind of, I'm too cool even to acknowledge you exist, kind of face that supermodels will have in certain fashion shoots where they just are expressionless and kind of almost zombie-like, you know? I am so cool, don't look at me, no, please look at me, not like that, I don't know who you are, go away, you know?
DVF 字母组合之前还在用。现在变成了用 Helvetica 体写的“Diane von Furstenberg”几个字。它看起来很干净、很中立、很聪明，但它在最糟糕的时候（不一定是在这种情况下，我是指）它也具有那种阴沉、冷漠、有点像“我酷得甚至不屑于承认你存在”的表情，这种表情超级名模在某些时尚拍摄中会有，她们面无表情，几乎像僵尸一样，你知道的？我很酷，别看我，不，请看我，别那样看，我不知道你是谁，走开，你知道的？
And so, the hell better can kind of have that quality. And I just think it can be a mean withholding typeface. So I have a bunch of listeners, they're design aware, they're design engaged. And as a person who puts things out in the world and makes logos and makes new logo systems for people, what would you want them to know when they interact with you? What type of criticism would you like to hear or not like to hear?
所以，Helvetica 体会带有那种特质。而且我只是觉得它可能是一种刻薄、吝啬的字体。所以我有很多听众，他们对设计有意识，对设计很投入。作为一个把作品推向世界、制作标志并为人们制作新标志系统的人，当他们与你互动时，你希望他们知道什么？你希望听到什么类型的批评，或者不希望听到什么？
I sort of deal in a field where like almost like a lot of the things that define what I do kind of comes down to really boring sort of sayings like don't judge a book by its cover or on the other hand you only get one chance to make a first impression and so they all kind of contradict each other you know and you know the advice I give is that at the end of the day graphic design is really important but it's also kind of one of the most cosmetic things in the world.
我从事的领域里，很多定义我所做的事情的准则，最终都归结为一些非常无聊的俗语，比如“不要以貌取人”，但另一方面又说“你只有一次机会给人留下第一印象”，所以它们在某种程度上互相矛盾，你知道的，我给出的建议是，归根结底，平面设计非常重要，但它也是世界上最流于表面的事情之一。
If you can read an exit sign, you're going to get out the door. If the door doesn't have a door knob on it, if it's nailed closed, these are all things that are real impediments. But that exit sign can be in any typeface you want and you're still going to find the door. And so I think it's, you can make a handsome exit sign that actually fits the architecture around it. You can make one that's hard to read, and that one is gonna be dysfunctional,
如果你能读懂出口标志，你就能走出大门。如果门上没有门把手，如果门被钉死了，这些才是真正的阻碍。但那个出口标志可以用你想要的任何字体，你仍然能找到那扇门。所以我认为，你可以制作一个与周围建筑相契合的美观的出口标志。你可以制作一个很难阅读的标志，那一个就会失去功能，
but there's a lot of different ways to do it, and usually it's not a life or death thing. I think there's a lot of things that are like really life and death matters in the world, and really important and worth getting agitated about. I think that probably logo design shouldn't be one of them. There's people that are paid a lot of money to care desperately about the way logos look,
但有很多不同的方法来做到这一点，而且通常这不是生死攸关的事情。我认为世界上有很多事情真的是生死攸关的生死大事，非常重要，值得去为之激动。我认为标志设计大概不应该是其中之一。有些人拿很高的薪水去拼命关心标志的外观，
and I aspire to be one of those people. I think that if you're not getting paid to do it, like try not to do it too much, only do it to the degree it entertains you, but then move on to more important things. Michael Beirut is a partner at Pentegrin. I'm the proud owner of a signed copy of his book, How to Use Graphic Design to Sell Things, Explain Things, Make Things Look Better, Make People Laugh, Make People Cry, and Everyone's
而我渴望成为其中的一员。我认为，如果你没有因此获得报酬，那就尽量不要太纠结于此，只有当它娱乐了你的时候才去做，然后转向更重要的事情。迈克尔·贝鲁特（Michael Bierut）是 Pentagram 的合伙人。我很自豪地拥有他签名的一本书，书名是《如何利用平面设计卖出东西、解释东西、让东西看起来更好、让人笑、让人哭，并偶尔改变世界》。此外，他和杰西卡·赫尔芬德（Jessica Helfand）还是播客《设计的商业，商业的设计》的共同主持人。
In A While, Change the World. Plus, he's the co-host along with Jessica Helfend of the podcast, The Design of Business, The Business of Design. It's really good. If you're looking for insights into the world of design and designers, you need to subscribe to it and its sister podcast, Debbie Millman's Design Matters, which is like the OG of design podcasts. They're essential listening. So I have to do the credits and some very important announcements first, but we have a special bonus interview at the end of the episode, which is a clip of a live event I did with my friend, Kevin Smokler, about the places,
真的很棒。如果你正在寻找对设计和设计师世界的深刻见解，你需要订阅它以及它的姊妹播客——黛比·米尔曼（Debbie Millman）的《Design Matters》，它堪称设计播客的鼻祖。它们是必听节目。所以，我首先得播报鸣谢名单和一些非常重要的公告，但在本集节目结束时，我们有一个特别的彩蛋采访，这是一段我和我的朋友凯文·斯莫克勒（Kevin Smokler）共同参加的一场现场活动的片段，讨论的是你最喜欢的 80 年代电影中那些真实与虚构的地点。
both real and imagined, from your favorite 80s movies. Kevin's new book is called Brat Pack America. It's super fun, especially for anyone who grew up on those movies where places like Shurmer, Illinois, Hill Valley, The Goondocks, Sherwood, Ohio, were characters in and of themselves. So stay tuned for that. 99% invisible is Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Kurt Colesde, Taren Mazza, Katie Mangle,
凯文的新书名叫《Brat Pack America》（小鬼当家美国）。这非常有趣，特别是对于任何伴随着那些电影长大的人来说，在这些电影中，诸如伊利诺伊州舍默尔、山谷山（Hill Valley）、古恩多克斯（The Goondocks）、俄亥俄州舍伍德等地方本身就是剧中的角色。所以请拭目以待。《99% Invisible》的成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kohlstedt）、特伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）、凯蒂·曼格尔（Katie Mangle）、
Sean Riel, Avery Hoffman, Sheree Fusef, and me Roman Mars. Astute listeners from over the years might notice a name missing from that list. Sam Greenspan. Sam starred out on the show as a remote intern based in Baltimore when it was just me and my apartment in Richmond, California. He was the very first person I hired for the show. Actually, you guys hired him during the first Kickstarter in 2012, and he's been a critical part of our team over the years. He is moving on to do his very own project which we're all really excited about. It's too soon to tell you anything about it yet, but I want you to remember this word.
肖恩·里尔（Sean Rial）、艾弗里·霍夫曼（Avery Hoffman）、谢丽·菲塞夫（Shree Fusef）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。多年来的老听众可能会注意到名单上少了一个名字：萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）。萨姆在节目刚开始时是一名驻孟加 terc 的远程实习生，当时基地只有我和我位于加州里士满的公寓。他是我为节目雇佣的第一个人。事实上，你们是在 2012 年第一次众筹期间雇佣他的，这些年来他一直是团队中至关重要的一部分。他现在要去做他自己的项目了，我们对此都非常兴奋。现在告诉你们任何细节还为时过早，但我希望你们记住这个词：
Bellweather. You can be one of the first to know what he's up to by following him on Twitter at Sam listens and signing up for his tiny letter email newsletter at Samgreenspan.org. Good luck Sam. We at NaNiPiHQ and the listening audience will miss hearing you on our show. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. So a few weeks ago, I had a conversation in front of a live audience at Spur in Oakland
风向标（Bellweather）。你可以通过在 Twitter 上关注 @Sam listens 并注册他在 Samgreenspan.org 上的 Tiny letter 电子邮件简报，来第一时间了解他的最新动启动。祝你好运，萨姆。我们 Nanipi 总部和听众都会怀念在节目中听到你的声音。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的 Radio Row。几周前，我在奥克兰 Spur 的现场观众面前，与我的好友凯文·斯莫克勒就他的新书《Brat Pack America》进行了一次对话，
with my pal Kevin Smokler about his book, Brat Pack America, which is this like 300 pages love letter to all the places where your favorite 80s teen movies were set. I really enjoyed the book and our conversation, but after I recorded it, I learned that if you aren't as well-versed in the 80s movie genre as I am, you might get a little lost and the conversation just worked way better on the website.
这本书就像是写给所有你最喜欢的 80 年代青少年电影拍摄地的一封长达 300 页的情书。我非常喜欢这本书以及我们的对话，但录完之后我了解到，如果你不像我那样精通 80 年代电影类型，你可能会有点迷失，而且这段对话放在网站上效果会好得多。
We could bet all the pictures of the places that we're talking about in the trailers from the conversation just worked way better on the website. We could have bet all the pictures of the places that we're talking about and the trailers from the movie along with the audio of the event. It's one of the coolest web features we've ever done, so I hope you check it out. Here's a little clip of our conversation. The locations in Ferris Bueller are all within the downtown loop and Riggly field.
我们可以在网站上附上我们正在谈论的地点所有的照片以及电影的预告片，还有活动的音频。这是我们做过的最酷的网页功能之一，所以我希望你们去看看。这是我们对话的一小段剪辑。《春天不是读书天》（Ferris Bueller's Day Off）中的取景地全都在市中心商业区和瑞格利球场（Wrigley Field）内。
And, I mean, that's one of the things that struck me. I watched Ferris Bueller again a couple of nights ago, and they kind of have a lame sense of Chicago. Oh, they sure do. It's really like, it's really touristy. Like, they're not there because they really know Chicago. They're there doing the exact same things that a literal field trip from school would take them to.
我的意思是，这就是击中我的点之一。几天前我又看了一遍《春天不是读书天》，他们对芝加哥有一种很烂的审美。哦，他们确实有！真的非常游客化。就像，他们去那里并不是因为他们真的了解芝加哥。他们去那里做的完全是学校的实地考察会带他们去的事情。
Yeah, I mean, for kids who live like three train stops away from Chicago, they act like they're there from Cody Wyoming or something. Like, you know, I mean, all they need to do is like get a slice of deep dish pizza. Like, they've completed their sort of day of touristing around Chicago. And to be fair, and this is only very slightly so
是的，我的意思是，对于那些离芝加哥只有三站火车距离的孩子来说，他们表现得好像自己是从怀俄明州科迪（Cody）之类的地方来的一样。你知道的，我的意思是，他们只需要吃上一片深盘披萨。就像，他们已经完成了在芝加哥观光的这一天。公平地说，虽然这只是非常微小的因素，
John Hughes was a white socks not a cubs fan and so he wanted to shoot the Riggly field scene at Kamiski Park which would have at least taken them to the south side of Chicago But the the socks were not in town that that weekend and so they had to film it that film it much to his Chagrin at at Riggly field so yeah yeah, it's a really like not adventurous day off. And the funny thing is John Hughes himself, even though he was very aware of himself as a deweller in the North suburbs of Chicago, went all the heck all over the place. Like I spent a lot of time with one of his kids,
约翰·休斯（John Hughes）是个白袜队（White Sox）球迷而不是小熊队（Cubs）球迷，所以他原本想在科米斯基公园（Comiski Park）拍摄瑞格利球场的场景，那样至少能把他们带到芝加哥南区，但那个周末白袜队不在城里，所以他只好在瑞格利球场拍摄，令他懊恼不已。所以，是的，这是一天非常缺乏冒险精神的假期。有趣的是，约翰·休斯本人，尽管他非常清楚自己是芝加哥北郊的居民，却到处乱跑。比如我和他的一个孩子花了很多时间在一起，
and John Hughes wrote everything down. And he used to write down like all the concerts he would go to, and the art exhibits he would go to as a teenager. The guy, the guy mapped all of Chicago on foot. And somehow we get this very myopic, parochial picture of Chicago in Ferris. Here are the full interview trailers, picks, and links to Kevin's book, Rat Pack America,
约翰·休斯把所有事情都记了下来。他过去常常记下他十几岁时去过的所有音乐会和艺术展。这家伙，这家伙用双脚步量了整个芝加哥。但不知何故，我们在《春天不是读书天》里看到的芝加哥却是一个非常短视、狭隘的画面。完整的采访预告片、图片以及凯文的书《Brat Pack America》的链接，都可以在我们的网站上找到，
on our website, 99pi.org. America on our website 99pi.org. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible, you must go to 99pii.org Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 99pi.org。America 在我们的网站 99pi.org 上。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并点赞。我们所有人都在 Twitter、Instagram 和 Spotify 上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听《99% Invisible》的所有节目，你必须访问 99pi.org Radio tapio。来自 PRX。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。